and some other news here this afternoon
an off-duty pilot was on The Right
Flight at the right time yesterday a
Southwest Airlines pilot suffered a
medical emergency on board the flight
had just departed from Harry Reid the
pilot apparently had stomach pain before
they took off and then fainted or became
incapacitated thankfully a credential
pilot from another airline was among the
passengers that pilot then entered the
flight deck and helped to the radio
communication while the second Southwest
Airline Pilot flew the plane back to
Vegas the FAA says they were in the air
for roughly an hour before landing